how are you thinking about short form
content like shorts and reels and tick
tocks and I know you've got the MKBHD
shorts Channel where some of the stuff
on that has been cool but for example if
again if you wanted to you could 10x
your output on short short form content
to think and you could be thinking hey
Tick Tock is where all the kids are at
let's just bang out the content on Tick
Tock but it seems like you're not going
down that approach so yeah how do you
how do you think about tick tocky type
content yeah okay so that last point you
made is really very close to how I think
about it is like the the demographics of
our audience so again uh I'm 28 a lot of
my audience is right from about
14 to 35 let's say just like 15 years
less to maybe 15 years older just
somewhere on there and endlessly
probably undefeated with creators what
I'll see is as they get older their
younger audience that was closer to
their previous age becomes less
interested and I guess their older
audience becomes more interested so when
I see Tick Tock I'm like that's where
the youngest parts of my audience will
inevitably be if I want to talk to those
people and anyone using tiktok that
doesn't mean you're a child that just
means like that's the average of what a
tick tock scroller is doing if I want to
reach that younger audience I guess I
should be on Tick Tock but is that my
goal or am I really just concerned with
reaching the same people who are making
a purchase decision who who have some
disposable income who have a choice to
make about what piece of tech to buy and
maybe the age of those people isn't
going to change I mean it's cool to get
kids into Tech I still think I that's
awesome and I think there is probably a
cool way that we can make short form
content that is interesting to younger
audiences and maybe that's a net
positive because we can get people
interested in Tech and that's cool but I
think the Target demographic is actually
the same age as it's always been whether
it's shorts or longer videos or podcasts
or anything like that
hmm so it sounds like you don't feel
that pressure of like I've spoken to a
bunch of other creators who and myself
included who sort of feel that pressure
of ah crap Tick Tock is where where all
the new people are everyone shows that
like maybe YouTube is on the decline am
I gonna stay relevant by uh am I going
to try and force myself to stay relevant
by kind of adapting and becoming a tick
tocker as well yeah okay so that's a
different question so relevant if my
goal was just to be famous which I don't
want then I would be all in on Tick Tock
right but here's a different way of
thinking about it when I'm going to
search for the new iPhone comes out
where do I go look for that video I go
to youtube.com and I type in the YouTube
search box that is where I want to live
for those people who are searching for
that information if that answer ever
changes if it's like the new phone came
out let me go into Tick Tock and see
what people are saying about the phone
then I guess that is when I'll feel that
pressure but I think for the people who
feel the pressure to be relevant or the
pressure for the eyeballs or the fame or
something like that then you'll feel the
pressure because Tick Tock is 100
accomplishing that now the most viewed
piece of content I have ever made in 15
years is a 12 second Tick Tock of me
unfolding the LG wing it has 35 million
views if I wanted the eyeballs I would
be all over Tick Tock but I think it's
different it's just that people
searching for things the people making
purchase decisions I'm trying to make
valuable content for them and so that's
still YouTube so that's why I'm thinking
of it I'm just out of out of curiosity
if you were to look at your analytics do
you find that most of your growth comes
from search or is it mostly through like
home page suggested the browsy type
features growth interestingly comes from
the browse and suggested but I still
feel that like slightly intangible like
section of it's almost like time based
when I when you look at the comment
section of a video like the first three
to four or five hours of people
commenting on video are not people who
came from search there are people who
subscribed who found it with browse then
like a week or two later there's people
who are searching on the subject and
then and watching the video and then
commenting and that's a whole new
separate crowd that might not be the
YouTube growth you're after but you can
still see the value in that so we sort
of optimize the content for both of
those groups of people but they're very
different times
so do you then change titles like you
wouldn't believe this phone versus a
Google pixel 6A review and I kind of
know the answer to this because I I
don't see you doing those sort of browse
type clickbaity type titles particularly
yeah I I see those titles and it comes
down to again like what what I want to
watch what would I click on what would I
want to subscribe to and sometimes I do
see this title on thumbnail which is
just like because you know you're you're
doing the analytics you're like oh I
have to have a face and a thumbnail I'm
gonna have a sort of a clickbaity
blurred out object you wouldn't believe
this oh check it out I I don't click
those I don't watch those videos if I
was thinking wow every time I click one
of those I am very happy with what I
watched then I would probably explore
formatting my content like that but I
think if you just name it what it is
can't lose right that's it you're gonna
get what you came for yeah there's no
way you're let down I told you exactly
what you were getting into we we play
with like the the post text formatting a
little bit sometimes play with a little
pun at the end of the title but you know
what you're getting hey friends thank
you so much for watching if you enjoyed
this clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day bye